my husband and I are kind of in a unique
position the only doubt we've had with
student loans which we were working
really hard towards paying off you know
with covid they end up getting deferred
but we still you know took the same
amount of money and just put into
savings and we don't pay them off well
I know that's kind of a a touchy topic
with you our mentality is
he's he's waiting to see if the 10 grand
Is Forgiven how much do you owe his are
around 80k and mine are what the hell's
10 grand got to do with it you owe 80
grand well it could be 10 grand less
that we give to them how much have you
got in the bank we well we did have
about 90k we had reached the amount that
he had so here's the thing Anna if you
owe eighty thousand dollars that you
signed up for and you have ninety
thousand dollars to pay it you should
pay it you owe the money I don't want to
have to pay it for you I'm a taxpayer
that has to pay this because you're
trying to play some freaking game with
the government